ces deux mois que jean pierre nous a
quittés mois et demi ou deux mois et
demi comment tu vas aujourd'hui est-ce
que tu arrives parce que bon ça qui
arrive ou pas où tu y as des eaux il ya
débat il ya
jeu on survit comme on dit qu'on survit
en pleine jungle guillaume avec le temps
ça va passer ben moi je trouve que plus
les journées passent et pierce et je je
je vois pas d'amélioration parce que au
début on se dit ah bah il est parti
travailler moi je suis en tournée ou
voilà un mois j'étais quelqu'un on était
très indépendant aussi c'est à dire que
moi des fois je partais une semaine en
vacances tout seul voilà on n'était pas
tout le temps et j'y vois là j'ai
l'impression qu'il va franchir la porte
et il a franchi pas mais mais il est
présent il est présent à côté de moi il
est ça je suis 100% sûr c'est pas pour
me dire pour me rassurer ainsi parce
qu'il ya plein de gens guillaume c'est
pour te rassurer 90 pas pu me rassurer
je sais qu'il est proche de moi qu'il
est à côté de moi qui me protège comme
il l'a toujours fait d'ailleurs on s'est
toujours protéger mutuellement je vais
sauver la vie plusieurs fois maintenant
c'est lui qui me sauve et c'est lui au
moins le jour je partirai il sera le
premier à me retrouver les enfants
communs comment ils vont les enfants
c'est compliqué c'est très difficile
vraiment ah oui c'est très normal à deux
mois et demi c'est sa famille dit un
militant j'ai 18 ans j'ai pu te papa
tellement jeune sympa pas et c'était
leur mentor ils étaient tellement un bon
père tellement généreux avec ses enfants
lose lose bien sûr à l'été sur les
réseaux où elle rigole ou et mâcha mais
chaque enfant est complètement différent
elle rigole parce qu'elle essaye de
montrer une autre facette mai elle
pleure énormément j'ai vu qu'on lui
avait reproché à une ligne mans de
rigoler sur les réseaux combien
exactement série des cons qui
s'emmerdent et qui doivent faire des
critiques moi je trouve que ma fille
énormément de courage parce que elle
veut montrer un côté positif comme l a
dit son deuil ses personnels donc c'est
clair que le soir et ben comme moi on
pleure elle ne pas pleurer dans mes bras
parce qu'elle va être forte pour moi
dans quel cdn pour une gamine de 19 ans
de soutenir sa merde pas de pleurer
devant sa mère parce qu'elle va me
soutenir elle a été triste de ce qui
s'est dit sur les réseaux parce que
c'est vrai que j'ai vu sur les réseaux
des bus kallel ou la fille de jean
pierre qui a fait pas mal de vidéos il
ya plein de deux d'abrutis qui ont dit
oui son père vient de partir elle fait
des vidéos sur les réseaux c'est honteux
c'est inadmissible est ce qu'elle est ce
que ça la salle à payer ou bien au début
oui au début oui puis après diop merde
c'est ce que je lui dis j'ai dit tu
faisais quand tu te mets sur les réseaux
il faut tout accepter il y en a qui sont
contents il y en a qui sont pas contents
jeudi l'essentiel faut que toi tu sois
bien dans ta tête c'est ce qu'elle
prenne ce qui est primordial et en
direct à raison moment donc des fois
leur balance des bonnes pic et puis dit
l'essentiel les gens qui me connaissent
bien et qui même une comprennent